je me détestais en misant mais
finalement je suis tellement mieux le
système en rien faire et c'est tellement
pas suffisant que succès en fait
vous êtes totalement à sa merci et vous
avez l'impression que sans lui vous êtes
absolument plus rien et qu' il a
totalement raison
il m'a fallu énormément de temps pour
arriver à m'en sortir et commencer à
remonter la pente et à reprendre
confiance en moi et surtout à apprendre
à me réveiller en fait ce qui est
vraiment pervers effectivement pour le
coup c'est que ces pervers d'un sicsic
eux n'ont aucune confiance en eux donc
effectivement pour arriver à exister par
rapport à vous ben oui vous attire
vraiment très très très très bas pour
arriver à eux avoir l'impression
d'exister tout ce que vous faites tout
ce que je faisais était sujet à moquerie
c'est pas suffisant
c'est pas comme ça qu'il faut faire
pourquoi tu fais ça pour quoi tu
demandes ça pourquoi tu veux des choses
particulières donc rien n'allait jamais
donc c'est pour ça que ça a été ça a
était quotidienne c'était permanence des
récurrents et et surtout il vous exclus
de tous vos cercle familial parce que
s'il ya d'autres personnes ou mes amis
où l'on sert famille ait effectivement
voyez je n'allais pas bien il vous
empêche d'aller les voir moi j'avais
j'avais pas le droit d'aller voir mes
parents pour éviter tout toute réaction
toute rébellion et cetera pour qu'il y
ait un contrôle permanent sur moi
[Musique]
c'était l'équipe henry c'est le déclic
pour moi parce que je me suis dit il est
hors de question cette personne soit le
père de mes enfants c'est impossible
c'est juste totalement impossible donc
effectivement jeudi mis à la porte et ça
a été ça a été terminé mais j'ai
l'honnêteté de dire que s'il n'avait pas
fait ça je serais pas parti jour là
[Musique]
lorsque j'ai quitté ma relation avec mon
ancien compagnon gt1 52 kg c'est un proc
est beaucoup trop bas pour moi j'ai pas
la morphologie pour pour tenir à points
à 52 kg j'aime lorsque je joue au tennis
et que je faisais du sport toute la
journée j'ai jamais pesé ce poids là
c'est pas la morphologie de base que
j'ai et mon système immunitaire était
beaucoup trop faible et lors d'un énième
voyage parce que je voyage énormément et
que je travaille énormément parce qu'ils
me disaient éternellement je travaillais
pas assez que c'était pas assez ce que
je faisais effectivement j'ai été piqué
par un moustique j'ai fait quinze jours
à 40 de fièvre
j'ai pas pu m'alimenter pendant quinze
jours donc j'ai perdu encore trois kilos
donc je suis descendu à 49 et à partir
de là c'était une spirale absolument
infernal mais mais parce que j'avais
entamé ce processus d'anorexie ans ma
femme ans pour essayer de maigrir appui
possible pour qu'il arrête de me lire
tous les jours que j'étais trop grosse
et trop grasse
[Musique]
oh
on suit entre des lignes blanches et qui
a un fils est devant moi que j'ai une
raquette dans les mains c'est mon
domaine c'est ce que je sais faire et là
je suis en sécurité
et ça a été vraiment ma thérapie et je
m'en suis je m'en suis sorti grâce à ça
absolument si j'ai des lots seront
donnés en tout cas des conseils à donner
à d'autres femmes qui sont dans la même
situation que moi à partir du moment où
vous avez l'impression que votre
compagnon tout ce que vous faites c'est
pas je sais jamais assez bien toute
façon on partait ça sert à rien
d'essayer de rester ça ne s'arrangera
pas ça à faire que s'empirer
ce qui est très je pense très important
de dire c'est que la personne qui vit
avec vous ne vous aime pas y'a aucun
amour pour vous aucun ce qu'une personne
qu'on va vous aiment vraiment elle n'a
pas envie de vous faire du mal
alors que cette personne n'a hélas
uniquement pour vous faire du mal pour
vous détruire
donc il n'y a aucun amour appartement il
ya aucun amour ya aucune relation
possible